Grazie
il fumettisti hanno una marcia in più
loro non inventano delle storie
inventano degli interimondi c'è un
universo parallelo
in cui Eccolo qua l'universo parallelo
spider-man alle stampelle
quindi
supereroe in un altro mondo con le
stampelle Io ho le stampelle e sono in
questo mondo ma ho un superpotere
vedete quando io passo
le persone si girano
le persone si girano mi guardano o la
loro attenzione
era un bambino quando l'ho scoperto e
non avevo la più pallida idea di cosa
avrei fatto di questo superpotere mi
dicevo
Passa uno con gli occhiali e non lo
guarda nessuno passo io con le stampelle
e mi guardano tutti
gli occhiali hanno fatto passi evolutivi
enormi Adesso sono un oggetto bello chic
Cool di design C'è chi si fa fare con le
lenti neutre pur di poterle mettere
le stampelle no
le stampelle sono brutte stigmatizzanti
come si diceva all'inizio
e quindi Tu associ stampella a
disabilità brutto a disabilità
Eppure gli occhiali
hanno
ispirato anche loro un supereroe
credo che i fumettisti siano più avanti
in questa sala sicuramente molti di voi
portano gli occhiali
dubito fortemente che ci siano molti tra
voi che si sentono disabili
ovvio
questa binomio bruttezza e disabilità
mi ha fatto pensare mi ha fatto pensare
parecchio e spider-man mi ha fatto
pensare perché spider-man dice Da grandi
poteri derivano grandi responsabilità e
lì ho capito Grazie a spider-man con
avrei usato il mio superpotere avrei
fatto in modo che quando la gente mi
guardava non avrebbe più visto delle
stampelle ma avrebbe visto un oggetto
Wow
possibile
In verità
io non avevo solo bisogno dell'oggetto
Wow che può Giusto gratificare Il mio
narcisismo che non è poco
io avevo bisogno di un ausilio un po'
più efficiente un po' tanto più
efficiente per andare in montagna perché
io vado in montagna amo la montagna da
morire Sono andato in cima al Monte Rosa
ci sono andato con un paio di stampelle
normali le ho rinforzate mi sono fatto
le mie otto ore per arrivare in cima
me ne aspettavano ancora otto a scendere
poi mi sono seduto sulla neve ghiacciata
fredda a sedere e ho guardato il
panorama stupendo ma poi
ho guardato le mie mani erano devastate
Erano piedi di fiacche di piaghe dovevo
fare ancora 8 ore a scendere e dopo aver
guardato le mani mi sono concentrato sui
miei dolori dolori muscolari dappertutto
sulle spalle alla schiena le braccia e
ho detto basta Non si può andare in
montagna con delle stampelle così quello
è il momento in cui ho deciso che le
stampelle sarebbero cambiate
ora
Voi vedete queste stampelle avete in
mente forse Cosa sono le stampelle
normali
e devo spiegarvi tecnicamente cosa è
cambiato semplice quando io appoggio e
faccio il passo L'asta è a 90 gradi sul
terreno
non è difficile
le stampelle tradizionali hanno sempre
un angolo minore di 90 gradi
su questo palco che è in discesa con un
paio di stampelle tradizionali per terra
ma non solo
voi Avete presente le stampelle
tradizionali come sono fatte Come si
regolano hanno un perno passante Ok quel
perno passante vuol dire o ti fai andare
bene questa altezza o quell'altra
queste No hanno un tubo che chiude su un
tubo come sellino della bicicletta eh
non è che ho inventato niente
ma quel perno passante
dopo un po' si slabbra Io immagino che
voi lo sappiate le stampelle si sentono
prima di vederle
immaginatevi un ragazzino di 17 anni che
deve tornare a casa a mezzanotte lucido
ci siamo già capiti
arriva a mezzanotte e mezza luna ed
entra piano piano in casa e ciccì
Renato è questa l'ora ad arrivare Ecco
questa era stata la mia adolescenza
immaginatevi un amante della montagna
che passeggia
Oh guarda una marmotta
Senti che bello il vento che soffia tra
le chiome degli alberi CC senti cosa
no doveva cambiare tutto bene È cambiato
tutto Non bastava le signore in questa
sala mi aiuteranno e mi confermeranno
che se esci quella borsetta sbagliata
cambia tutto
Allora tu sbagli il colore della
borsetta e ti Cavoli come una bestia
io vengo qua e vi parlo della stampella
di spider-man e c'ho sulle ragnatele se
venivo con Una stampella verde Dovevo
parlare della stampella di Hulk
per dire è un oggetto che tu usi che è
tuo è come gli occhiali quindi colori
quindi materiali Giusti perché lo prendi
in mano migliaia di volte al giorno e
quindi un materiale anallergico morbido
non è che si chiede chissà che cosa
allora
Ve l'ho spiegata in tre minuti ma ci ho
messo 10 anni
Cioè tu prendi una mole di problemi
li Traduci in un oggetto che riassume e
semplifica la soluzione e passa del
tempo
in quel tempo sono cambiato io ma sono
cambiato profondamente una volta ero
sapete quei disabili supereroi Ecco
quelli che quando fanno una roba ti può
arrivare in cima alla montagna Wow e
tutti bravo Ce l'hai fatta Sei un grande
io ero così
sono ancora un po' così
sono cambiato perché prima ero
orgoglioso delle mie imprese adesso sono
orgoglioso perché ho fatto un oggetto
semplice che semplifica la vita agli
altri e come i supereroi ho dato una
mano niente di più niente di più
naturale
non era più il tempo in cui io devo
dovevo conquistare la montagna
era il tempo in cui dovevo
sono stato conquistato dalla montagna è
cambiato tutto
e quindi cambiando io erano cambiati i
miei desideri io stavo cercando il mio
posto Io sono diventata una persona
rilassata pacifica prima ero
ci sono eh i disabili Sai quelli
aggressivi agguerriti un po' incazzati
col mondo E peraltro anche un qualche
diritto
ma il mondo non gliene frega niente se
tu sei incazzato meglio che ti rilassi
meglio che trovi il tuo posto i miei
quattro sassi Ecco la montagna quando mi
sono rilassato mi ha insegnato la
semplicità
la pacificità
c'è voluto molto tempo
perché trovato il posto i quattro sassi
andavano sistemati ristrutturati Resi
vivibili e accoglienti ma alla fine ce
l'ho fatta
quegli sforzi sono stati ripagati e la
semplicità che cercavo l'ho trovata
ma a questo punto voi legittimamente mi
chiederete Quindi sei venuto qua ci hai
fatto tutto sto Pippone di quella fatica
gli investimenti
le tensioni per dirci che la semplicità
quella che ti rende felice
Eh sì Devo dire che è quello cioè non è
che c'è molto altro da dire
ma anche voi chiunque di voi quando
intraprende un viaggio
E durante il viaggio che capisce
veramente se vuole arrivare a quella
meta o se a metà strada dice no non era
proprio lì che volevo andare è il più
fortunati cambiano strada
E allora come spider-man alla fine di
ogni avventura Cosa fa uccide il cattivo
si toglie la tuta e torna a casa a casa
sua pacifico è un bravo ragazzo e sereno
spider-man quando non ha la tuta Anch'io
sono sereno spesso magari oggi no ma
spesso
Il problema è io sono convinto che
dentro ognuno di noi ci sia un
superpotere il mio superpotere a farmi
guardare e non sapevo cosa ci avrei
fatto E adesso tutti mi guardano e
dicono però bella bella
Il concetto di bellezza è quello che ci
salverà tutti su qualunque tema è la
bellezza e la serenità
e ho scoperto che chiunque di noi può
diventare un supereroe io ho la mia
ricetta per carità non vale per tutti
per molti però sì
tu guarda guarda chi ti guarda
osserva chi ti osserva
nella tua stranezza c'è il tuo
superpotere
[Applauso]